we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question about a possible
bubble that maybe is about to burst
let's take a listen
hey David this is Josh from Kansas City
I just got a quick question
I watched some of your videos on the
economics and as far as the recession
goes well I wouldn't say some your
videos on economics but anyway some of
your videos about the economy you stated
that you don't see a bubble like you did
with the housing market but could the
bubble possibly be in the market itself
with all the stock buybacks yes
I mean I work on the phones as a
customer service rep the financial
industry no expert but it just seems
like that could be a possible area where
the stock is overinflated yeah you're
completely right so I've said I don't
see a housing market bubble right now
the way we've seen previously and in
fact I think that there's been I think I
read a 7% decline in housing prices I
don't remember if that's nationally or
here in Boston or maybe Massachusetts
but there is no question that there very
well may be a bubble in the stock market
and what's important to understand is
that bubble may be significantly caused
by Donald Trump's tax reform because as
I told you one of the things that big
corporations have done on the basis of
Donald Trump's tax reform plan is not
give people raises not it's not reinvest
back in the company although anecdotally
that some companies have done that it's
use the tax windfall to buy back stock
pushing up the price and there indeed
may be a stock market bubble there may
be a lot of retirement accounts and
pensions that are about to take a hit if
and when we see that pull back but I
completely agree with your analysis
we've got a great bonus show today we
will talk about what's going on with
Pete Budaj edge in Iowa we will talk
about the cost to become a US citizen
there is a cost and it's going up quite
a bit and we will talk about theory over
a $50,000 visit by Donald Trump jr.
which is now a very very angry with the
Florida student who participated in
organizing that visit all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member and I hope to see you
there